okay guys it's December 20th I'm
chastity we just revealed our top five
games of the year which you can check
out at GameSpot calm after I give you
the news here's what's new
first GTA 5's Christmas update is out
now here's what it brings
Grand Theft Auto 5s Christmas update is
out now bringing new items bigger awards
and more to GTA online Twitter user it's
Jack Frost reported details of the
festive surprise 2016 event rockstar has
confirmed those details the event brings
a load of Christmas themed clothes
including some fetching jumpers
available for free
there's also Santa and gingerbread man
themed masks plus up to 50,000 in bigger
rewards when you sell vehicles stolen
from the recent import/export update to
new car variants the trifid narrow and
narrow custom are available for purchase
and other items such as custom
apartments and a selection of guns get a
25% discount in addition all the content
from previous GTA online Christmas
events including the firework launcher
will return players can also enjoy
double RP and cash in the new turf wars
adversary mode and triple RP for
participating in the latest premium Sun
race called plummet next up details on
Call of Duty infinite Warfare's first
expansion Activision today officially
announced the first expansion for Call
of Duty infinite warfare titled sabotage
the DLC adds new multiplayer maps
including noir Renaissance neon and
Dominion the last one is a reimagining
of modern warfare 2 ZAF Kanak the
sabotage DLC also includes a 90s themed
zombies expansion in the form of rave in
the redwoods
unlike the bright and colorful zombies
in space land which had an 80s theme
Raven the Redwoods looks like a dark and
scary horror game with a raid going on
this is explained away by fictional
director Willard Wyler played by Paul
Reubens who has the ability to bring
people into his worlds as for
multiplayer maps check out the official
descriptions on GameSpot calm and
finally we've got Sam's winter sales
start date I suspected it sounds like
steams annual Winter Sale will begin
this Thursday December 22nd the PayPal
UK Twitter account spilled the beans on
the start date just like it did in 2015
earlier this month multiple reports
claimed that steams Winter Sale would
begin on December 22nd and run through
January 2nd 2015 steam winter sale also
started on December 22nd and ran until
the beginning of January last year the
sale offer discounts on thousands of
games and software while there were also
win
Sail theme trading cards available
exclusively during the sale period at
the time of writing the steam winter
sale hasn't been officially announced so
we don't have information on specific
offers we will have all that information
for you as soon as we can on
gamespot.com let me know what you think
of today's stories in the comments below
and don't forget to go to gamespot.com
to learn about the new Naruto
live-action movie and for all of your
movie content head over to GameSpot
universe on YouTube it's GameSpot's
permanent home for TV movies and comics
as of January 3rd subscribe now so you
never miss a video
I'm Cassidy and I'll see you tomorrow